the official hogwarts legacy gameplay
reveal showed off more than 14 minutes
of gameplay footage and there was no
shortage of epic moments for longtime
harry potter fans so for today's video
we're gonna go over the top five biggest
reveals at the hogwarts legacy state of
play number one and there's no sense
beating around the bush guys you already
know the single most epic moment in that
entire trailer i think for just about
any harry potter fan was seeing that
avada kadavra is in the game at least in
some form be careful where you choose to
explore as it may lead you down a darker
path
[Music]
there's a lot we don't know about it yet
there's a lot of questions people still
have about when you get it in the game
how often can you use it is there some
kind of cool down meter how is it going
to work but regardless of all those
questions after all this time it is
absolutely incredible to have it
confirmed that it is in fact in the game
i know that is one that people have been
wanting for a long time not to mention
the other unforgivable curses as well
but the fact that they showed it near
the end of the trailer it really just
felt like it had been building to this
moment they knew that was going to be a
big reveal that was going to please a
lot of fans and i've tried to watch it
multiple times i want to see who they
are casting it on but it doesn't really
show you it's hard to see who they're
hitting with that spell okay whereas
avada cadaver is something that everyone
had specifically wanted we really wanted
that to be in the game number two kind
of came as a bit of a curveball and that
is the room of requirement menagerie not
just the room of requirement i think we
knew that had to be in the game in some
form right but the way they're handling
it is in a very interesting way by
having it almost serve as what appears
to be like the hub for your missions and
quests throughout the game
a helpful house elf named deke helps you
discover the variants that allow you to
nurture your own menagerie of magical
beasts what is it
deek isn't sure
only one way to find out you can freely
customize this space to reflect your
personality and magical specialties i
mean it looks like set up a house you
have pets in there you can bring magical
creatures back and nurse them back to
health and then if you also take a
closer look from the outside here you
can see that there are other rooms or i
think they called them vivariums not
gonna lie i had to look that word up and
it means a terrarium used especially for
small animals so there you go if you
didn't know don't feel bad i didn't know
either but i think what's so awesome
about this space is it really shows they
heard the fans who were wanting this
extra level of customization that
frankly i never thought would be in the
game so this is one i think that nobody
really saw coming yes we saw the room of
requirement but having this whole sort
of extra space that we can customize and
nurse creatures back to health and is
just something that i think is a great
idea by whoever came up with that at
avalanche all right moving on to the
next one and this is certainly another
long time request of harry potter fans
and that is day and night cycles as well
as seasonal weather we're gonna lump
these two here in together as you
explore you'll find the world
surrounding hogwarts is alive with
activity wonders and areas of unusual
interest
as the school year progresses dynamic
seasons and climates will fill the sky
with lightning or sunshine or coat the
ground with snow or rain one of the
staples not only of the harry potter
movies but also of the harry potter
books is the seasons that you go through
within each novel a lot of fans can
point to specific holidays as pivotal
moments in the series i mean just in the
first book alone you have troll in the
dungeon all that happened on halloween
that christmas is when harry gets the
invisibility cloak and it was the
absolute best christmas of his life he
couldn't even believe that he woke up
and had presents and one thing the
movies really did a great job of is
showing the progression of each season
and it seems like the game is going to
follow in those same footsteps now
here's the part i am most interested
about and i haven't seen a lot of people
talking about this when it comes to the
day and night cycles and that is how
long are they actually going to be most
often in games they're going to be
simulated right it could be an hour it's
a full day but another reason that i'm a
little bit more curious about this is
because you think back to those room of
requirement menageries that we were just
talking about in there you see there are
some actual real world timers on some of
those potions at least it appears to me
to be real world timers now maybe there
are things we can earn throughout the
game that are going to speed these up i
know as soon as people saw this they
really started worrying about
microtransactions good news on that
front if you didn't know already they
have confirmed officially no micro
transactions channel wood went to
twitter and said that and then they also
have updated the official faq so no
microtransactions in hogwarts legacy
however that still leaves the question
of is this an actual real world timer
now i don't want you to think that i'm
suggesting the whole day night cycle is
tied to our real world clock similar to
something like animal crossing because i
don't think they can afford to do that
in a game like this i think we're going
to need to progress and go through
multiple days much faster however i do
wonder how they'll balance their day
night cycles with these seemingly real
world timers that we have here now
another thing i've also seen people talk
about is that seasons almost has to be
confirmation that we will be getting
multiple school years at hogwarts rather
than just the fifth year which is what
i've kind of been thinking for a while
now now i actually love this line of
thinking i mean it kind of makes sense
right which you really want to program
seasonal weather in for just having it
change one time but here's the tricky
part and it relates directly back to the
day night cycles you see they control
how long these are and so how long these
days are really is what sets the overall
length of the game if you think about it
because games have to find some way to
show that progression of time without
having you actually sit there through
every single hour every single minute of
the day animal crossing is a rarity in
that and then the other big thing we
don't know about the day night cycles is
how do you progress them so is it
actually a timer and you're sneaking
around the castle at night and you could
actually run out of time like you could
stay out all night and then morning
starts to rise and you have to get to
class is that how it works or is it
similar to what the older games and even
what some more current games have done
in that you actually have to progress to
the next day so it will stay night for
many real world hours if you want to and
then you choose when it's time to
progress it is that how it works and see
that's what i think is so interesting
about this how are they going to
approach this because you think about a
game like breath of the wild link
doesn't have to worry about going back
to a school to go to different classes
that are set at different times
throughout the day he can just roam the
world freely as much as he wants so the
sun rises sun sets it rains it snows and
he's just running around doesn't matter
he doesn't have anyone else to kind of
report back to right whereas in the
hogwarts legacy we do have that
connection back to the school and these
classes i'm sure they'll handle it in a
very elegant way i just think that's a
big question that we really still don't
know the answer to regardless i am super
pumped super excited that day night
cycles are in as well as the seasonal
weather changes i think it's going to be
fantastic for the overall feel of the
game all right for the next one let's
jump back to yet another one that a lot
of people were asking for and that is
customizable gear they showed that shot
in hogsmeade of our character being able
to go into different shops purchase all
sorts of different items and then they
showed this little sequence right here
where we can see all this different gear
that we can put on our character this is
something again that people have been
asking for for a while now one thing
they did not show that you guys are
super interested in and that is the idea
of a customizable wand customizable
wands that is something i see so often
in the comments and i've just been going
and responding to everyone saying the
wand chooses the wizard it's not always
clear why but in all seriousness i would
like to see this i wouldn't have a huge
problem with it i know it kind of would
break the canon a little bit because of
the fact that the way it works in the
world is you really don't get to choose
your wand the wand chooses you now maybe
once you have the wand i don't know if
you want to like make certain carvings
in it if you want to like put little
ribbons on it if you want to paint part
of it a different color maybe those
things they could figure out a way to
work in there or maybe you have sort of
like the base one and then you can just
customize things like the handle i do
think there are ways they could make it
work and still stay relatively true to
the harry potter lore okay real quick
before we get to the last one i have to
give some honorable mentions because
there were just so many epic moments for
long time fans in this gameplay trailer
i couldn't not talk about the house
elves in the kitchens i love seeing this
shot we've imagined this in our heads
but we've never been able to see it on
screen because the movies did not
include the house elves in the kitchen
so i love that they did this i just want
to go hang out in here and sit with
these house elves and listen to what
they talk about throughout the day maybe
we can even get side quests and things
from them another big one the prefix
bathroom they absolutely nailed this you
have all the fun little knobs they even
put the diving board in there and then
our final honorable mention is the house
common rooms they did a fantastic job
with gryffindor and slytherin but it's
the ravenclaw and hufflepuff common
rooms that everyone is talking about
because of how little we have seen of
them we never saw them in the movies in
the books harry goes to the ravenclaw
common room but the hufflepuff common
room first time any of us ever seen it
and i know a lot of the hufflepuff folks
out there were super pumped for that so
just seeing those common rooms even
though it was such a short glimpse we
could see the attention to detail we
could see how different and how true to
each house they made those so those
three honorable mentions there i just
could not in the video without talking
about them and then last but certainly
not least this one was not even
mentioned in the gameplay trailer at all
this actually happened after the fact
and it was almost like they were trying
to hide this i don't understand why they
didn't make a bigger deal about this but
that is the fact that hogwarts legacy is
coming to the nintendo switch guys i
made a video months and months and
months ago about hey i wonder if they're
going to actually not bring the games to
last gen if they're going to make this
just next gen only so drop the ps4
version no in fact they're taking it a
step further they're going to say it's
on anything and everything pc xbox
playstation nintendo switch wherever you
wanna play if you have a fairly recent
gaming console or one of the new gaming
consoles or a pc you will be able to
play hogwarts legacy in fact if you're
in the us i know for sure that
pre-orders have opened up i'll put a
link down in the description below if
you're in other parts of the world and
interested in pre-ordering keep an eye
out because they have been popping up at
various retailers now as i always
caution people pre-ordering is entirely
up to you i am personally waiting
because i am holding out hope that we
get a collector's edition at this point
we don't know about that yet so those
for me guys were the five biggest
reveals but i want to hear from you what
was your favorite reveal of the new
gameplay trailer let me know in the
comments below as always thank you all
so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon